you can't really mention anyone that
says anything
really bad about me except for him
because i got away
amber rose is speaking out against
ex-boyfriend
kanye west i'm not like
him at all right i didn't get anything
from him
during an appearance on the no jumper
podcast the 37 year old model slammed
the rapper
for having quote bullied her for over 10
years
amber and kanye began dating in 2008 she
says she ended their relationship
in 2010. i've been offered
book deals to talk about him that
wouldn't make me happy
to even if somebody is like picking on
me
which he has for ten years he has picked
on me for 10. he has bullied me
for 10 years in july kanye brought up
amber at his bizarre presidential rally
in south carolina
where he compared her to quote
prostitute mary magdalene
he called me a prostitute and like
10 years later just leave me alone i
don't bother you i don't talk about you
really stood out as like a weird thing
to throw on somebody that you shared so
much with you do
right so like you share two years with
someone someone
you take them around the world you buy
them all the jewelry
you shout out to the world how much you
love them and how much
fun you have with this person and then
the person
decides that this isn't what they want
their life to be
i opted out amber also recalled when
kanye famously said in 2015
he had to take 30 showers after their
breakup
i don't know if he says things to make
his wife more comfortable
um but to [ __ ] shame me and say
you needed 30 showers it's like
bro right took me around the world
like since when do you need 30 showers
and i deal with that every day
that same year amber opened up to e.t
about the incident
and how comments like these towards
women are a serious
issue i've um just recently dealt with
that with
my ex saying that he had to take 30
showers
um after he's been with me
we were happy when we were together and
now all of a sudden i'm getting
slut-shamed because we're not together
anymore and it's unfair
and i feel like women deal with that
constantly on a daily basis
i'm sick of it